this has become the way el-hadji hasn't
spent most of his afternoons since the
21 year old returned home to that ugly
two months ago he says drawing helps him
temporarily forget his five years as a
child soldier which have scarred him
mentally and physically
I used to hurt cattle and soldiers came
up to me and said I will join the army
they said I am no longer a civilian and
that I became a soldier and if I don't
defend the village women will be raped
and killed
I used to fire RPGs and also record
attacks to document them for the group
and Heidi says he was 13 when the armed
opposition known as the Sudan's people
liberation movement north forced him to
join their ranks the SPLM has been
fighting sudanese government for
assistance 2011 the conflict has killed
tens of thousands and displaced hundreds
of thousands more most fled to
neighbouring South Sudan the conflict
became one of three in Sudan all marked
by human rights violations and
atrocities there is no exact numbers on
how many child soldiers they are in
Sudan but rights groups say most are or
have been part of armed opposition
groups and while recent reports suggest
that none are in the ranks of Sudan's
army the reports show some are part of
the paramilitary Rapid support forces
rights groups say the rapid support
forces recruited children after the war
in Darfur where they're accused of war
crimes the New York Times also reported
that child soldiers are employed to
fight for the saudi-led coalition were
in Yemen some as young as 14 paid as
much as ten thousand dollars and the
rapid support forces are accused of
killing at least 100 pro-democracy
protesters when they're sitting was
attacked in Sudan's capital Khartoum
four months ago the RSF and Sudan's
government deny recruiting children
Abdullah we've conducted training within
the ranks of the rapid support forces
and have not recorded any use of child
soldiers and to avoid being accused of
recruiting them the RSF raised their
enlistment age from 18 to 20 but some
soldiers tend to have young looks and
small bodies so are mistaken for child
soldiers the United Nations Children's
agency UNICEF says that it's working
needs to dance neutrons
additional government to verify soldiers
ages and we'll demobilize child soldiers
if they find any there is a strong
commitment in terms of the military of
the nation but we as UNICEF have been
speaking with the RSF and we have gotten
the same assurances that we can come in
that we can verify it has begun so it
will be a question of access so where
there is access we'll be able to verify
well heidi says he wants to rebuild his
life even though his recruitment meant
his missed out on getting an education
while his yet to recover from his days
as a child soldier he's hoping his
future isn't hindered by his past Heba
Morgan al Jazeera Kath ugly South
Kordofan